okay so if you cast your mind back to
2009 then you might remember that x-men
origins wolverine was meant to usher in
a new kind of comic book movie that
would take characters from the already
established fox franchise and show us
their origin stories however after that
movie went down worse than army hammer
at a vegan festival their plans were
cancelled like the delta variant and
they shelled the second project which
was going to be a standalone magneto
movie from here fox decided to combine
the majority of the slate into x-men
first class a prequel for the franchise
that would recast the characters and
show us how things came to be before the
first x-men film first class totally
revamped the series and for me it easily
sits in the top three alongside logan
and days of future past inside the film
is one scene that completely blows me
away every time i watch it and
throughout this video we're gonna be
breaking down exactly why i love the
coin moment that comes at the end of the
movie if you agree that this scene is
amazing then please smash the thumbs up
button and right now i'm using my
professor x powers to make you subscribe
to the channel not doing this would be a
mistake like you spelled mystique's name
wrong and i promise you that we put the
neato in magneto so you definitely want
to stick around probably not after that
intro but with that out of the way thank
you for clicking this now let's get into
x-men first class
okay so in my opinion magneto is one of
the best comic book villains ever put to
film whether it's mckellen or fassbender
playing him he's always an enemy that
you can sympathize with and though you
don't agree with what he's doing you're
able to see exactly why he's the way
that he is
first class is very much his
supervillain origin story and we start
the film with a shot for shot recreation
of the one from the first x-men film
here we're introduced to eric lencha a
jewish boy who grew up in poland during
the 1930s and 40s as i'm sure many of
you know jews were hunted by nazis
during this time and over 6 million of
them were killed in death camps simply
because of the way that they were born
understanding this is of course crucial
to understanding why eric hates humanity
so much as he has seen firsthand how
people's prejudices can lead to
extermination i've been at the mercy of
men just following orders
never again in the x-men franchise we
see as someone's powers manifest during
times of stress and their adolescence
and eric being separated from his family
kickstarter's ability to manipulate
metal i remember seeing this scene in
the cinema for the first time all the
way back in 2000 and it blew me away as
i knew that cinema would be changed from
that point onwards superhero movies up
until len hadn't really tackled any
truly dark subject matter yet here we
were faced with one of the worst
atrocities ever committed birthing one
of the most powerful supervillains ever
now where things shifted was that we
were introduced to a brand new character
in kevin bacon sebastian shaw if you've
studied history then you'll know that
these death camps were filled with
scientists carrying out human
experiments in order to quote unquote
improve humanity shaw very much
represents these scientists and he makes
the perfect villain as we know from real
life exactly how bad that they were
hitler believed in the aryan superman a
race of blonde head and blue-eyed people
that he thought descended from the
nordic gods what's worrying about this
scene is that we know because of his
abilities that eric will be studied and
this is confirmed when we see shaw
telling him to move a coin eric is
unable to do this and this sure has his
mother brought in who he then executes
in order to trigger his abilities it's
the callousness here that lets you know
how little shaw thinks of humanity and
also sets up a quest for revenge within
eric that drives him throughout the
entire movie interestingly the five
reichsmark coin was made of silver which
has a weaker magnetic structure than
most medals so even if eric was slightly
more advanced with his abilities he
would struggle moving this even when
unleashing his powers in the room the
coin doesn't shift and sure places it in
his hand which starts off the quest to
avenge his mother from here we go to the
title sequence before joining him as an
adult still hunting for the man who
destroyed his family the scene here
beautifully foreshadows the end of the
film as eric flies the coin directly
into a picture of shaw's forehead which
sets up exactly how he kills him at the
end of the film
now the movie follows eric as he teams
up with xavier and the x-men in order to
stop shaw's starting nuclear war between
russia and america we experience the
cuban missile crisis firsthand and eric
rushes to stop the villain who up until
this point has been blocking out
professor x by using a helmet that stops
telepaths inside the reactor of his
submarine eric encounters his enemy who
apologizes for what happened in the
camps when he was a child however he
states that he did this in order to make
him stronger and we very much watch as
his callousness is reflected in eric the
reactor itself is sealed off and thus
xavier can't get through to his mind but
after using himself as bait eric
destroys the room and brings forth pipes
and beams whilst shaw goes off on his
villain monologue he pins eric against
the wall and implants the idea on him
that they are the future of the human
race we are the future of the human race
it seems like eric is going to join him
but this is a trap and he pulls the
character's helmet off and thus charles
is able to enter his mind and hold him
steady now what happens next is
breathtaking and eric steps forward
takes the helmet for himself and at this
point he becomes the villain we know and
love staring shaw directly in the face
he says
if you're in there
i'd like you to know that i agree with
every word you said it's chilling as we
know that magneto genuinely believes
that shaw is right and that humanity
must be extinguished in order for the
mutants to rise up however there's just
one problem shaw killed his mother and
he can't let that slide perfectly
mirroring the scene from earlier in the
movie eric holds up the reichsmark and
says that he's going to count to three
and then move the coin just in the same
way that he was helpless as a child shaw
is in the same position unable to do
anything and simply stuck there watching
his death play out eric has the chance
to be the better man but because he's so
fixated on revenge he doesn't care
anymore i would rather have his mother's
death avenge than be part of the new
family that we watched him create
throughout the movie it gives me chills
every time i watch this and eric slowly
moves the coin through the air towards
shaw's head who due to his abilities
immediately absorbs it however because
he's not in control of the situation
he's unable to manipulate the incoming
object and thus it rips directly through
his brain now the person who also has to
feel the weight of this is of course
charles who's stuck in an impossible
situation if he let sure go he will of
course succeed and destroy all of
humanity however if he holds him in
place he'll be murdered and charles will
partly be responsible for this xavier is
a person who would rather always save a
life than cost it and this has been seen
throughout the franchise hell even in
days of future past we watched as he had
wolverine sent back in time to save
mystique when the easier option would
have been to basically sarah conoho he's
someone who will try and protect life no
matter what but here his hands are
completely tied and all that he can do
is watch on as eric rips through the
head of his nemesis the direction here
is outstanding too and just as we pan
across with the coin tearing through
shore's head we watch as the same camera
movement happens with charles who simply
stands there screaming as he sees it all
play out it's one of the best death
scenes in a comic book movie ever and it
subtly hints to us how both charles and
eric will be on opposite sides of the
fight from this point onwards charles is
someone who can of course control
people's minds but here he's unable to
convince eric to do the right thing and
it shows just how powerless that he
really is it really speaks to how even
with the best intentions that it's
impossible to change some things and it
really hits home why we are all likely
doomed to travel down a darker path if
we live with hate in our hearts they are
truly broken apart because of this and
whereas charles would rather save his
enemies aka the humans eric is happy to
kill them in order to achieve his goals
it's symbolic on a number of levels and
just as we watch shaw get taken down we
see someone with the same objectives
same helmet and almost the same team
step into his place the worst thing is
that we know magneto was born out of
pain and that from this point onwards
the quest for revenge will never stop
for him he emerges from the submarine a
new man and he decides to launch the
missiles in order to allow humanity to
destroy itself charles tries to convince
him that the men on the boat are just
following orders and we know from our
own history that this is what many of
those complicit in the holocaust gave us
an excuse for why they did the things
they did it truly is the moment that one
of the world's best supervillains is
born and every time i watch this scene i
just get chills whether it's magneto
accepting that he agrees with shaw
moving the coin or knowing that charles
is completely helpless it has it all we
can truly see from the film exactly why
magneto came to be this way and it also
explains why he'll travel on the path
that he does in the future what's
heartbreaking is that after charles is
shot eric holds him in his arms and
thinks that they're still brothers he
says that they want the same things but
xavier shoots down this idea and says
that they don't it really is a great
scene that separates the two and though
i was going to do the bar moment from
earlier in the film i think this just
edges it out in terms of bringing the
arc full circle and also giving birth to
a man who ended up becoming a monster
whilst trying to destroy them it ends
the film in an incredible way and for me
is completely perfect
obviously i'd love to hear your thoughts
on the scene so make sure you comment
below and let me know we are running a
competition right now and giving away
three copies of zack snyder's dc trilogy
on the 30th of september all you have to
do to be on the chance of winning is
like the video make sure you subscribe
with notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the scene we
picked the comments at random at the end
of the month and the winners of the last
one are on screen right now say that to
you then message me on twitter
heavyspoilers you want emails to watch
them make sure you check out our
breakdown of the perfect scene in
spider-man homecoming we point out
exactly why the moment in the car with
the vulture is absolutely outstanding
and it's definitely worth checking out
if you enjoyed this video if not then
thank you for sitting until the end of
this one i've been paul i'll see you
next time take care peace